hello wife and welcome to this video
playing Alexa okay this is one of my
worst opponents minus seven I don't know
I don't know why I usually have good
position and then screw them okay this
was what I recently remember I played
some stupid move all here forgetting
about the caption okay now I did capture
currently so good start okay this is a
normal way of playing this rear ooting
the bishop to g7 okay interesting yeah
you can normally take here and play e5
in case of beatings this probably also
possible here okay let's do it he can
take c 6 foot that is usually enough
compensation with blacks bishop and
better development I'm just referring to
the type of position not the specific
one which is definitely not
theoretically explored okay he takes the
porn probably he doesn't have much of a
choice there anyway okay um can play the
bishop also somewhere like to eat six or
should geforce also move let's go bishop
you for me
okay I can take on the phone now even
like also rook c8 is the one well I'll
go back you fight my five might hang
though yeah anyway I'm making the usual
mistake of pondering too long in a
position that is good anyway so let's
try to speed up well I'm what I'm
basically saying is this compensation
that I have for the pawn is long term
anyway so it doesn't really matter that
much what specific move I play I guess
so I should just play one move but do it
quickly I recently had a game against
him that I also completely screwed up on
time from a very nice position
de5 can have rook c-54 lots of activity
yeah it's not clear what White's movers
I also okay so let's do that quickly
should be five unfortunately doesn't
work so let's take this pain 95 we
should be five is a funny move 94 I mean
we should be fine there's a funny move
see for Bishop c5 it should be good
so look III I guess or is there anything
better no I don't think so
yeah looks looks good more or less
winning for black Queen the one Bishop
c4 and disrupt III has a pretty big
threat
yeah well I had a couple of games like
that against him and some are still
managed to lose so let's see
and that looks very bad however you have
to admit Queen d2 this rookie too that's
also pretty convincing
the equity one is the only move that
somehow continues and then Bishop c4 the
night moves as root d3 winning the Queen
i'll be taking the rook and I'm
threatening root III so has a lots lots
of things wrong with white
yeah I'm getting 2-6 against him from
minus seven ok so this continues at
least but I probably can do a couple of
things ok to check I don't have any
checkmates here but i can check here
first we should be four maybe
yeah i roped you three check ok channel
let's do that don't see anything better
maybe there is something bad of it
white rose i Luke see one yes this one
to save a bishop yeah this is the line
that I had studied for my book and and
feel pretty confident that black is okay
there are various lines on here and they
are difficult to kind of differentiate
their Canada or somewhat similar with
black setup is comparable it usually
goes g6 bishop to have eight and white
does various things this is kind of
ideas is one of them but quite often
black can play in the way that I did in
the game like this and b5 um it's just
that black is potentially somewhat
better developed here yeah the Queen
sometimes has to lose time yet again and
Bishop c6 is a very materialistic move
so I don't know the engine wants to play
this hem there should be five Queen
moves Bishop g5 Bishop g7 and says equal
this is probably not such a great idea I
mean usually black has very decent
compensation here Oh Bishop g4 is the
engine move so yeah I wasn't sure at all
this should be seven okay the compounds
to do this and it says that this is even
better yeah you see how good blacks
development is seven and whites pieces
don't really coordinate well this is
what the computer is giving with black
being better almost by a pawn which is
quite a bit I know it's going down 0.6
0.7 yeah it's definitely the
compensation I've got two bishops very
harmonious position position here and
then what do I do the compounds to play
this and then place the bishop I am it's
not a bad idea strategically okay so
this is what happened and now I'm after
very long thought he took but this this
leads to
trouble I should be five was strong he
already okay now this is no playable
right because of this pin yep White's
development has too bad okay and this
this was running into you should be five
and now white is killed weekly to was
even nights it's the same it's the same
it just minus minus a million I rocky
one was stronger yeah but ok it it wins
the house wins the peace and this is
enough I want to be safe against and I
really have a history of spawning good
position some with it better safe than
sorry ok thanks for watching